[Music]
a while back we talked to so crispy
media about doing a video where we strap
a 360 video on top of a really big RC
car tracks has hooked us up with their X
max which is the biggest consumer RC car
on the market and what is the first
thing you got to do well you got to test
it out let's try it
it's kinda it's kind of fast
[Music]
yo this thing's got more juice than a
first-grade cafeteria
things got more juice than Lance
Armstrong
is it it send it up the back of my truck
never on tricycle ooh it's like you know
like Jedi is blocking lasers you have
Nerf darts so I wonder all the time I
have to do it once in a while that's my
job let me just baseball that one
Oh
well I can hear my hand can't hear with
the sword I think it's really
intimidating I'll put a mask on for this
one yeah that's me an alien costume and
tether really yep triggered the blast
shield down I can't even see how am I
supposed to fight your eyes can deceive
you don't trust them I can't see
anything I can't see anything so it
turns out we trying to gauge the
trajectory of like a dart with one eye
it's impossible today we have a call
with Puget systems they are a high-end
computer company that basically builds
awesome pcs for creators for each
individual creator they build a system
for you we called them up we got on the
phone we told them what rent had just
been dealing with with octane and they
said why don't we build you a quad GPU
based rendering system the reason why
this is so awesome
is that they're putting for GPS not just
any for the brand-new Nvidia 1080s for
10 80 's that's so many spins if you
guys gonna check out them actually
putting this computer together they're
doing a live stream on it this coming
Friday
so check it out look at the link swords
just slow me down I'll be like a month
from DMD
I hear most of it was my hand I stuck to
the movies real yes every single one
maybe a Jedi real-life no turns out
there is no force Sam Gorski likes to
live life on the edge
oh hey man
it's cool
smells like Thanksgiving here so it's
cooking a hand
shut up just fine yeah someone just
indefinitely I claim 50% two parts of
responsibility and then just pop that
back up any other pain I knew that was
gonna happen it's just a matter of time
I do that's gonna happen - but that was
like the best-case scenario you know
best case scenarios it doesn't happen at
all good it looks fine it's fine even
though we caused a lot of chaos in the
street we actually learned something
about this 360 video concept and that is
the xmax I think it's a little bit too
big with all the torque and the speed
that you get with the xmax you know it's
just this is gonna whip that little 360
camera around and you're not going to
get what you need and I spit on the lens
I hope you can see it right there did
you know that we have shirts on the
corridor digital store in fact we have
these new ones that gave designed based
off our glitch video we're all wearing
them around the office and if you guys
want to pick up your own checkout
quarter - digital comm slash store pick
one up for yourselves they make great
gifts for anyone who's a total nerd just
like you